foreign
which sounds like a place in a Dr Seuss
book and talked to Hannah what's up
Hannah hi how are you today I'm good
how's Kalamazoo it's a party it is it's
beautiful today we got good weather
finally that's outstanding outstanding
Winter's finally over hey so what's up
uh yeah so I'll just give you a little
background before I jump into my
question here
um I'm 29 years old I'm married I have
one child
um and I've kind of always struggled
with making friends I can talk to anyone
but when it comes to connecting on a
deeper level it's very difficult for me
um I kind of always thought it was my
personalities but after talking with my
sisters it seems like we kind of all
have uh the struggle in one way or
another so my question is could my very
religious hyper-critical Baptist
preacher's kids upbringing play a role
in why I struggle not at all you know
listen this is a hundred percent your
fault in your personality just fix you
and all this goes away right so yeah uh
wait say that again you said it
perfectly that's the best I've ever
heard it okay hyper-religious hyper
religious uh or sorry religious
hypercritical Baptist preacher kid over
here in Kalamazoo yes all of that yes
congratulations you are a therapist's
dream because you're going to be a
long-term client right
and every stage along the way
um your parents have friends
no yeah probably not
um
were you a living figurine for them to
show the world
yes I was yep were you put in a bunch of
awkward situations with adults and
told that your job was to make sure they
a were comfortable and B that they could
see how great you were
uh yes like like singing in prisons and
yes yep lots of random things like that
mm-hmm
ta-da
you are now a dysfunctional adult
congratulations
yeah pops up in weird places it does
tell me tell me uh tell me about where
it pops up
um so as I've gotten older I've just
kind of noticed things which you know
when you're younger you think they're
normal
um just just don't even feel the need to
connect with people on a deeper level
it's just all very shallow
um and compartmentalized like I have one
friend for this I have one friend for
this I wondering for something different
you know why you do that right
I do not
because you can't risk somebody actually
fully knowing you
yeah if they do there's this underlying
it and I'll even go as far to say uh by
the way I don't know if I talk about
this much on the show but halfway
through my life my dad quit being a
homicide detective and became a minister
at a large church so this is same team
discussion here okay
um if somebody truly knows you
the U doesn't have to be bad
it just has to be something they
disagree with
and then your parents
porcelain facade gets gets a mark on it
and that is so wired into every bit of
you and by the way the mark
is not just somebody at your church not
liking you it is eternal damnation and
burning in hell right I mean the stakes
are so insane
and so the risk is I I can't be fully
known
because if I'm fully known and I'm not
fully loved
I am Ash
and so you you I'm gonna challenge you
you said I I don't feel the need to
connect I disagree I think you
absolutely do
but you parse it out you Outsource it to
a bunch of different places
um to try to just get enough gulps of
oxygen to get through your day
yeah and that wears out
right yeah
how long have you
um tried to use your husband as an
oxygen tank
[Music]
been together four years yeah he's like
he's my person yeah he is more than your
person he's probably your
heroin syringe too right yeah
not that I know anything about what I'm
talking about from personally
um
yikes ma'am
so
how can I help because there's a lot
here right what what made you pick up
the phone and call
just I think I've never heard anyone
talk about this because I I've been
listening to your show for a while
um I hadn't I've been waiting for
someone to call in with this question
because I can't be the only one and
obviously I'm not
um so I I guess
it gets kind of weird uh weird to start
I don't know if that's finding someone
that is truly safe like speaking out
that one person or let's back up let's
back out of that out of there then
because we're not at relationship yet
here's here's a couple things I want you
to
um
that you're gonna need to make peace
with okay okay you did good things
through your entire childhood and
probably through your adult life
so that
other people would see you and think
good about you and think good about the
name of the family and think good about
your parents
that does not mean that the good you did
was of no value
and that doesn't mean that you're a bad
evil person
okay the relationships you had served a
purpose
they were currency for your family their
currency for you and you know fair you
know better than most
how to make other people feel good
because that's been your job
and that can be by performing that can
be by getting straight A's that can be
by looking pretty but not too pretty
right you know how to do all that stuff
and it is freaking exhausting
and it doesn't mean that the
relationships that you had Were Somehow
less than or false or fake
they were what you knew
and what killed me was how long I
discounted all the good I did Growing Up
because I was doing it for the wrong
reasons but I was a kid I didn't know
and so I've been able to over the last
15 or 20 years turn that around with
some help from a counselor by the way
and begin to see I got a lot of practice
in doing good and that is that has been
a great gift to me as I've been older
because it's just wired in
and now I've learned to do it for the
right reasons not because I'm trying to
perform because it really is kind of who
I am now
so I don't want you to Discount who you
are and the things you've done and where
you've been and where you've come from
because there's so much good there
there's a lot of growth too
but there's a lot of good there that is
that is in you at the cellular level so
you're not broken and not dysfunctional
you're not crazy
does that ring true yes yeah no yeah
that's great to hear okay yeah because
sometimes it can feel fake oh it feels
disgusting and fake yes
but also I've got buddies growing up
that went and got super high and beat up
everybody in trashed places and that was
fake too
that was there would be imposers too the
same as I was being a poser is Johnny
Jesus Freak
that was around drugs all the time I
shouldn't do them right see what I'm
saying like it's all all kids are trying
to figure out who they are and what they
are and they're practicing things and
they're practicing identities that's
that's the whole part of being a kid
and then I think there's a stunted
adolescence for
um
kids who grew up in the spotlight
whether it's a tiny Spotlight like a
local church or it's a spotlight of you
know kids of famous people there's this
weird thing where
you know that there's like you know you
can listen really quietly in your home
and know that so-and-so's cheating on so
and so and this greeder at your church
is really an awful person so you have to
grow up really fast
but your ability to experience freedom
and responsibility for your own
decisions is so restricted for so long
so you see a lot but you don't get to
experience a lot and that makes for a
weird 25 year old right
and there's this weird balance where
um
I want to be sexual with my husband and
I want to be Reckless but it also feels
weird because there's all this
background nonsense and then also I kind
of want to do this but this all of it's
just this weird moving and so the
antidote for all of that
is you to really begin mining
m-i-n-i-n-g like going
on an adventure to find out who Hannah
is
and what she loves what she doesn't
believe anymore
what she wants for her and her family
and that is best expressed in
relationships
and that's hard
I just threw a lot at you speak back to
me
yeah that is that's a lot
yeah it just feels very overwhelming I I
do think I've done quite a bit of work
here in my late 20s
um to see exactly who I am I've I've
kind of left the church and kind of
rebalanced everything to see okay what's
mine and what was my parents oh good for
you um yeah and that's kind of where I'm
at right now I'm still not in a church
or anything but I do think I'm trying to
rebalance exactly who I am but the
friend thing is not is not falling into
place for me okay tell me if this rings
a bell
often ministers kids grow up with this
idea that every decision is the Super
Bowl
and if I get this wrong date wrong this
one date wrong
or if I have this sip of this drink or
I'm with a group of people and Janet
pulls out a cigarette right all like
everything is Do or Die
and kids cannot carry that weight
and in the same way that my buddies who
are college athletic trainers are sure
are telling me that kids 18 and 19 year
olds are showing up to the university
with overuse joint injuries similar to
the elderly people
so they've got 18 and 19 year olds with
90 year old shoulders and 85 year old
knees and hips because of the insanity
of childhood Sports
you turn into a 21 25 28 29 year old
adult
who is so exhausted from carrying the
weight of every decision is the end of
time
and so the word I want you to tattoo on
your soul is practice
you've never fully sat down with one
friend and told them everything
you're just gonna practice that
and you're going to practice feeling so
exposed and so raw and so terrified on
your way home when you're replaying and
I know you do this because I do too you
replay every sentence did I say that
right are they gonna think this I should
probably call them uh I said that one
thing about that other person you do
that right yeah oh absolutely yes
because saying the wrong thing would
have ruined everything
and now
I want you to own I don't believe that
at all anymore
I didn't do X for this long I don't even
believe that anymore and here's why
that's ownership
and that's you just gotta practice it
practice saying no
practicing I don't believe that anymore
practicing practice
not answering a question because
answering questions got you gold stars
growing up practice just not yeah
practice just not answering just
I don't know what do you think and
everything in your body will be like
answer answer answer just practice not
yeah I don't feel so awkward and weird
and then what you're gonna find is you
have value Beyond being able to give the
right verse in the right context
you're gonna find that you have value
not performing
these lessons that you learned but
you're gonna suddenly find that those
lessons are a part of you in a really
deep and profound way
and ultimately every single relationship
is a risk
and so you're going to practice taking
that risk
I want to tell you one thing one one
heavy thing before I let you go okay
okay
your husband can't carry the weight of
all of this too
and so you've been married four or five
years right
uh two two years okay I've been together
four years you've been married too so
I'm 18 years down the road
and I've almost wrecked our train
several times
by overloading the tracks
that means he can't be a trash compactor
for all of it
I mean you're gonna have to find whether
it's a counselor whether it's some
friends at a local church and and slowly
peek your head back in whether that's a
group of women that you invite over and
just say
I've never had friends before so I'm
going for it it was gonna be weird and
there'll be two out of the six that
stick around
you have to just practice that
I can do that do you promise you won't
now hit the pendulum all the other way
and just hold a bunch of Secrets from
him and then not tell anybody and then
implode the whole thing all right I
didn't even think about that yep because
that's what I do that's what I do I just
toggle from everything or nothing and
neither of those things are helpful
they're not healthy
and I don't know if this helps or if
this makes you feel bad
over the last 30 years I've had entire
chunks of my life where I needed to walk
away for a minute
from corporate Church stuff
in in a way recalibrate
and sometimes that was with two or three
people that I really really trusted
sometimes that was with me
um in one person
that had some wisdom sometimes that was
me spending some time reading and
reflecting and writing
um
but when you grow up in that Spotlight
sometimes the the heat lamp gets really
hot
so I want you to know that you're not
broken you're not there's nothing wrong
with you
in fact taking some space I think can be
incredibly healthy and everybody's gonna
have an opinion about why you're doing
and what you're doing
keep yourself grounded with people that
you trust okay
okay
cool
sounds good sounds like a good plan will
you practice this and then holler back
girl at me you're supposed to say it and
you holler back girl but I'd love to
find out what happens when you
reach out to a few women and just tell
them everything
okay
get around doing that but yes I know it
feels insane it feels insane
it does goby Craig go hey go be crazy
enjoy it have fun
and trust me you're gonna get burned
trust me it's gonna go awkward and weird
and then trust me you're gonna find one
or two people that say the magic words I
thought I was the only one
and that will be the soil of a new
relationship new friendship
a person that will walk with you will
hold your arms up in the desert
and that person will be a living
embodiment of a different way to do
relationships and Grace and risk and man
it's incredible it's incredible when you
find it